session and i hope you guys an
interesting session last week you would
have had a chance to go through online
modules ever so for the actual start of
a session I would like to go through the
organization page that being set up for
this particular it's
okay I guess my voice is it going
okay I look into that of God later so
yeah this is a kind of a personalized
[Music]
I say heal so I think it's important to
let people know that they need to mute
that themselves yeah I did okay write it
down on the chat as well so please it's
a request from all the participants to
mute your mics as soon as you join the
meeting for the better experience
okay looks like it's better now
so let me restart it
going through I was about to go through
the organization page or the dashboard
that we have created for this training
program so I'll just walk you through
what exactly it is and how exactly it is
beneficial so over here that's the link
I can type down the link on the chat so
we have different tabs over here the
first one that starts with is the hope
tab so this particular tabs keep you
updated with all the things that we are
posting so like you know we have the
files and the presentation that is to be
used in today's session or the recording
of the previous session so you could
have all you could see all the updates
listed down in the home tab and as we
mentioned in the last meeting that we
have our forums as well so if you feel
like putting up your questions over
there and you want other participants to
reply on that or to interact with other
participants to get a better experience
of what the other participant is doing
so you could create the forum otherwise
we are going to create the forum topics
for all the recordings and the files
that were used in the session so you
would you could go back and track down
all the recordings and the files now the
other thing that is pretty important
that is the progress so all the
participants could track the progress
like you know what exactly have you been
doing on the educational side and on the
TV or info platform so I'll just show
you how exactly this works and how
exactly you could analyze it this is the
progress bar that is being shown for
this current week you have the timeline
that you could select the time range
that you could select where you want to
see your progress so let's say for this
particular discussion I'm going to
choose the start date of 10th of March
till 23rd of March I'm going to go and
click on apply
so now this particular time range has
been applied and I could see all the
progress that has been made and then
over here we have the points so for each
and at every activity that is being done
by the participant on the educational
side and on the server can be seen over
here so and moreover it is very
essential for all the participants to go
back and check out their online modules
soon after this session so that you know
you are up to the mark and you
understand what exactly was done during
the lecture so example the previous
lecture that we did you know could be
related on introduction to
bioinformatics so you can just go ahead
and the course and all the courses are
free for all the participants so you
could get a better understanding what
exactly was commodity infectious and
really like to call it or you know - red
red color codger
ah
[Music]
I did a bottle opener right with a line
it'll be you the one I love
sorry about that so yeah I would like to
call off a Phil's name Akhil Rajput he
has been pretty active with all the
activities that he is going through so
just to have more information like you
know how exactly that the participants
are doing we have a small click on
button of information over here so I
could get more information about like
what exactly okay yeah I guess I have
some network issues so you can have like
a personalized information when you
click on the information button so
that's more about the progress and the
last thing is I would really like to
thank everyone for taking out the time
to fill out a survey form that was
circulated last week and thank you for
letting us know about your education
background and the projects that you
guys are interested to work upon that
was insightful and we will make sure to
reach out to each and every participant
and try to know their interest and their
project idea so that you know we could
start getting ready for the project and
you could have a more clear
understanding when we will be going
through the the data analysis steps on
the T value for platform so I would
really thank you guys for filling up the
survey form and letting us know more
details about yourself now without
wasting more time I would like to
welcome mr. Elia broadsky to continue
with today's presentation
Thank You Sahil and again yes as we can
hear the sound for people that are that
are joining and if you could please mute
yourself and to heal maybe you can make
sure that people that recently joined
their microphones are off and anyone
that wants to say anything you can
there's an option here to raise your
hand that might be a useful way to get
attention to whatever you want anywhere
if you and I just mentioned something
please put it in the chat so thank you
thank you for giving a little bit of an
introduction to how things work I do
want to mention that on the survey
results it seems like a lot of you have
been actively publishing and also you
plan to utilize the skills acquired in
this training program to advance your
research so this is very good we'll try
to be in contact personally with some of
you that are interested we know already
from the first survey which project
seemed to be more interesting and so as
soon as we get to the point of knowing
how to process the data knowing how to
find the data that's interesting to
process and then downloading it and
making sure that it's all available
we'll be transitioning into that phase
of working on independent projects so
today's session is focused on processing
of next-generation sequencing data to
yield things look like someone else
joining so we can again here
okay so please if you're just joining if
you're just joining please mute your
microphone that will help everybody else
hear much clearer thank you so today we
want to talk about processing of
next-generation sequencing data and we
want to talk about it in two ways and
first is the role of pre-processing so
he'll can you please mute whoever has
their microphone on yes I need that I
can still hear someone in fact I can see
that it's VOC you probably and there's a
few people and so the role of
pre-processing is important to
understand because it is related to the
technology of next-generation sequencing
and then the second big portion of
processing next-generation sequencing
data is going to be focused on mapping
techniques so we'll talk about several
different approaches to mapping before
we start let's talk about how do we
start with next-generation sequencing
data and how we can utilize the data to
do research of biological mechanisms and
what kinds of biological mechanisms we
can study with next-generation
sequencing data you're probably familiar
with this but just to give you an
overview genomic data is something that
has been available only recently and how
did we get to this point in the 1950s
the DNA structure was discovered and
then very soon after that we started
everybody was aware of the DNA and the
role plays in molecular biology and in
the 1990s the human genome project kind
of brought that front and center for
everybody to be aware of the revolution
that this type of data could bring to
our understanding of human health and
disease and so the human genome project
really opened up a lot of those datasets
but it was a transit
from a standard sequencing method to a
new sequencing that eventually was
popularized by Illumina and so a lot of
times when we say next-generation
sequencing today we will be referring to
Illumina sequencing even though other
methods are available and so Illumina
really made it much more affordable but
their methodology needs to be understood
so that we can probably properly address
the processing of next-generation
sequencing data so in 2006 Illumina
launched their first sequencer and as a
result you can see that the time kind of
accelerates from there
in 2015 we already had 1,000 genomes
that were available and very soon after
that in 2018 now we have access to over
100,000 genomes that were sequenced and
that are being used for research but
also in reference to health and disease
and biomedical purposes so in terms of
how quickly we got to the data about
many different organisms but a lot of it
is about the human genome of course has
been very fast and really got
accelerated because of this
next-generation sequencing technology so
today we want to talk a little bit more
about what that technology really does
how do we get that sequencing data and
then we want to talk about how to
address the preparation technique that
next generation sequencing uses to
produce the data as well as how to map
on these different genomes that are
available to us in different
repositories like NCBI now Justin I want
to turn it over to you so that you can
say a few words about next-generation
sequencing in terms of how it's used and
how it's changed at research
Justin
so next generation sequencing I'll just
say a few words about it really has
transformed how research is done in the
lab and because okay can you hear sorry
yeah technical issues greetings everyone
I'm Justin and before yo-yo goes into
some of the more technical aspects of
next-generation sequencing
I wanted to just make a couple points as
a neurobiologist who has an awareness
and appreciation of the technology and I
guess my first point I know we have a
lot of biologists and biochemists here
is NGS is not really limited and is not
used exclusively by biology it really is
applicable to many different areas and
one of the main reasons for that is as
it has developed it not only generates
lots of information and very quickly but
we are now alright from static it now
we're able to take all that information
and interpret it and analyze it so in
the beginning we were generating lots
and lots of sequences but that doesn't
do a whole lot of good if you can't make
sense of it
so my last point and of course we could
talk a lot about clinical applications
and many others is that this ability to
sequence very quickly and accurately
with precision
now if now allows us to make very clear
comparisons and accurate comparisons
between genomes and that's obviously
invaluable when we're trying to conclude
that one mutation or a sequence is
actually causative or involved with some
for example neurobiological disorder so
it's really exciting and for those of
you who don't have a strong awareness at
this point you should over the next 30
minutes so thanks for for listening and
I'll turn it back to Ilya
all right Thank You Justin yes so it's
really something that is important in
terms of impact and it already can be
seen I think in the lecture today how
the availability of data the
affordability of this kind of data can
play a major role in how we conduct
research so first of all how where is
this data right so that's one of the
things that we want to touch upon we're
going to be working on public domain
datasets and so I want to just briefly
talk about where do you find a lot of
this data so there are several things
that we need to understand about the
data that is available on places like
NCBI a lot of the publications that you
will be reading are going to include
references to a published data set that
was used to produce the results that we
discussed in the publication and in a
lot of the publications if you just look
for SR are right that SR R stands for
sequence read archive repository so this
is going to lead you to ncbi the SRA and
the SRA includes bio projects where you
can download the datasets and so at at
some point during the presentation I
want to give you a little bit of an
overview of how you get that kind of
data and how you can utilize it
throughout this program as well but this
is just a little preview so a lot of
that data has been repository I and is
available for us to reanalyze in the
datasets that we'll be using they all
come from ncbi the sra repository so
what is the sra format and what is
included and what kinds of NGS data
formats are there first of all the
Illumina sequencer will produce at two
types of formats and we'll kind of talk
exclusively about Illumina even though
there's some other ones and there is
some overlap there so there's you will
get formats like the BAM format the same
format but all of them
derivatives or could be converted to
some of these formats that we have in
front of us the fast queue and the fast
eight so what is the FASTA format and
the fast queue formats that we will be
looking at FASTA format so he'll if you
could please mute the people that are
joining that would be very helpful
so the FATA format is simply sequences
raw sequences of reads that are produced
through the next-generation sequencing
technology and those will be short reads
as you can see right here short
sequences that range anywhere between 35
and 215 base pairs in their lengths and
as they come for example in a reference
genome it could sorry it could be a
complete long sequence or it could be
short sequence reads just like you see
right here the fast queue format is
essentially a very similar format where
you have a sequence but you also have
information about the quality of that
sequence so for example the FASTA file
will be typically where you store a
reference genome so if you map on to
something you're mapping on a reference
genome and that reference genome will be
in FASTA format typically and so you can
see how it's just a continuous sequence
with the reference of which organism
that is and typically that organism will
also have a code an NCBI code something
like this and then a description of what
it is so that is on the FASTA format
what about the fast cue format the fast
cue format actually contains a lot of
the raw data that comes from the
sequencer itself so when we talk about
next-generation sequencing the way that
data is prepared is that DNA is shared
shared so you can see that it cut into
some other pieces between 200 and 300
base pairs long then adapters are at
- those sequences and then in flow cells
those elements are amplified so they are
amplified so that they could be read by
the sequencer and the sequencer
essentially detects letters based on
colors and so those colors have a
quality of signal the more clear the
color the more reliable is that signal
and so you can see that the fast cue
file contains that information it will
contain the sequence that the sequencer
read from the DNA and then you also have
a score that will be associated with
each one of those letters also we will
look today at how we have two types of
sequencing we have single and REE
sequences and parent sequences and so
single end would be sequences that are
just read from one side and paired end
would be read the same sequence is read
from both sides that technology is
considered to be more reliable because
now you have the same sequence read
twice so if everything is consistent
then you are probably looking at a very
reliable read of that sequence however
those individual reads the one that is
forward strand and backward strand are
going to be or forward direction and
backward direction sorry those are going
to be placed separately so you do have
to combine them together before mapping
next-generation sequencing is used for
many different reasons and so if we look
at kind of this overview of data from
phenotypic data what we observe
for example cell culture or tissue
images or some kind of phenotypic image
or phenotypic observation it could be
clinical data any other kind of data
that could be linked to for example
genomic data right so what is genomic
data those sequences will have
individual
letters that are in the read that we are
looking in and the reference and so by
looking at the difference between the
read and the reference we can identify
several different variations for example
substitution insertion deletion and so
we can look at a variety of changes in
the sequence then we can also look at
various epigenetic signals so
epigenetics has been a growing field in
its popularity and epigenetic data is
essentially the same next-generation
sequencing data but instead of looking
at the changes in the DNA in the code
that we have we are looking at histone
those areas of the DNA that are wrapped
around the histones so they're not read
easily and for example DNA methylation
so where we have CPG islands and
methylated sections that are also not
available for reading so those are the
epigenetic type of variations that we
can observe and learn through
next-generation sequencing data and also
we will look at transcriptomics so how
we can measure the expression and of
course all of these are linked together
right so we do want to study how changes
in the phenotype are explained through
the various types of data that are
contained in the DNA or in the
transcription process from DNA to RNA
and we can also go on and this is now
not related to next-generation
sequencing data but we can also look at
the product the proteins the metabolites
that are the product of mRNA being
translated into proteins so
next-generation sequencing in itself
covers a large portion of that whole
process and we can use it by processing
next-generation sequencing data that was
prepared with different types of
preparation kits and then we can measure
this signal it's up sometimes if we have
signal at multiple levels integrate
those signals to get a real systems
biology perspective on
what's going on and the underlying
mechanisms behind the phenotype that we
observe so what are some of those
processing tools that we have available
and we'll touch on throughout this
session RNA seek where we can study the
expression but when we talk about the
expression we're talking about gene
expression but we're also talking about
either form expression so how
alternative splicing can be observed and
how do we quantify it so that we can
measure for example differential eyes a
form or gene expression and how we can
study all kinds of rearrangements within
those isoforms we can also use chip seek
or a chromatin immunoprecipitation that
we can analyze interaction between a
certain target protein for example
systems or different components of
histones and how we can then study peak
calling and understand epigenetic
variation related to some modification
there's also microarray technology but
also this applies to the sequencing of
whole exome or whole genome sequencing
so we can study the actual sequence of
the DNA and then like we said we can
also look at RNA editing events various
repeats rearrangements and other things
that happen to RNA so there's a lot that
we can do with next-generation
sequencing data and now let's take a
look at how that actually translates
into the data analysis side of things
so on the platform that we looked at a
little bit last time we have a whole
dedicated section to next-generation
sequencing data that covers things like
RNA seek which would be the first one
right here you have RNA seek of
single-cell RNA editing and then under
genomics and epigenetics we have whole
exome sequencing or whole genome
sequence sequencing where you can detect
mutation based
we have bisulfite DNA methylation
analysis which is a whole genome or
targeted methylation you can identify
methylated regions of DNA chip seek that
we talked about just recently copy
number variation and we have a whole
section related to other types of
sequencing for DNA and RNA
for example unsupervised analysis of
non-coding RNA repeats genome
segmentation etc microRNAs and
metagenomics microbiome and also
amplicon 16s which is also related to
metagenomics so today we want to talk
about some of these methods in
processing this kind of data now as you
remember we talked last time about how
all of these sections have a consistent
interface and this consistent interface
will help us transition between the
different sections fairly easily so I'll
just go over this really quickly and
then we'll jump onto the platform so
that you can see how we can take a raw
sequence and see visualize what are
those reads in terms of their mapping on
a reference genome so you can if you go
in let me switch over to my computer
screen so if you go into your account
and please let us know if you have any
issues logging in once you're logged in
you should see your email address right
here and I think by now all of you
should be kind of familiar with the
interface if you have any questions you
can either ask today or you can also
post them here in the chat box as we saw
we have this next generation sequencing
section right here and let's go into the
RNA section so we can kind of see
practically how this is done so first of
all in every section on top you will
have this selection of the different
data formats and the different presets
that we have for
or starting your pipeline we have here a
variety of either model genomes that
have a good annotation and are already
pre-loaded on the system this is our
model genome GTF we have an option for
when you can upload your own genome for
example download a genome from MTBI
and upload it onto the server and then
you can map things to that genome or
sometimes you will have a genome that
comes with a GTF file so that is
something that you can see for example
on NCBI GTF or GFF is a reference file
that annotates the starting and the
ending position of genes and exons that
you want to use in your reference genome
here we talked about several of those
raw input data types we have fast queue
which is what we talked about it has the
quality score and could be they're
single and repairing FASTA which is just
reads without any information on the
quality sam and bam files and then also
sometimes you can use simulated files if
you would like to check how different
methods work or compare to each other
some of the organisms that have been or
by organisms I mean genomes of organisms
that are well annotated so if you use
our model genome GTF you can utilize
some of these pre-loaded organisms we
have arab adopts Asst two assemblies for
human mouse etc and human mouse
concatenated this is something that
we'll be using in one of our projects
and finally here you can select single
or parent reads once this
is set up you can go ahead and upload
files and groups and so when we do this
I just want to explain exactly how we
will do this so obviously you can select
for example the human genome and single
end and this is just a demonstration you
don't have to think in a little bit
we'll be creating a pipeline together so
you'll be able to use real files but I
just want to first go through the steps
once you click on upload data you will
be able to do a variety of things you
can upload data that you've downloaded
from NCBI for example and that will be
fast queue file like we just selected
you can also use reference links so
files that are already in the repository
on the system and the majority of the
data that we'll utilize throughout this
program in the beginning will be data
that is already on the repository as a
part of this program you right now have
a limit on upload so if you want to
upload a specific data set you have to
talk to us first tell us about the data
set we will make it available for you it
will be on the repository and then
you'll be able to utilize it and then
you have this option for reference link
so to explain and how that works let's
say I have a data set that is called
Ilya dot
fq okay let's say I have some file
that's called Neely FQ and I have
another file that is called Sahil that
FQ so fast Q files and I want to compare
one against the other so now I can see
that those files have been properly
configured and for example I can compare
them by dragging them into two separate
groups and then I can analyze the data
using different types of contrasts so
we'll talk more about this later right
now this first portion of the pipeline
has been prepared so we have everything
selected for the right type of upload
and we are able to now build our
pipeline so once you see that you have
the start option available and now you
can see that some sections or darker
some are lighter which means that you
can start using these sections the first
thing that you'll notice is that some of
these are organized into groups these
are logical steps so for example
pre-processing error correction mapping
on genome eggs on detection etc you can
see for yourself
and by selecting any kind of a button
you will see that it's connected so
later on you can understand what you did
to get the result that you were looking
at so if I want to go back I just press
the right button and now it goes back to
the previous step so this is a little
bit of an introduction on how the
platform is used if you once you create
a pipeline you will see under my
pipelines a number of different
pipelines that you've run and you can go
into inside the pipeline and see what
you did and sometimes you will have
outputs right here sometimes you have
visualisation outputs and you can we'll
talk more about the different formats of
outputs that will be useful for session
the first pipeline that we want to
prepare today is going to deal with
mapping the reads the raw reads and fast
queue files onto a reference genome so
again just like I was showing we have an
SRA file so this is a file downloaded
from NCBI and SRA all it does is it
compresses the raw fast queue file and
then we have a genome a reference genome
so this is something that was taken from
a publicly available data set based on
production of biologics so production of
vaccines a cell line that was used in
the production of vaccines and we want
to see how can we map those reads onto
the reference genome so let's do the
following you also have this
presentation so what we want to do is we
want to copy this first link
okay and create an rna-seq pipeline and
I'll just kind of walk you through the
steps we have here our genome because
we're just going to be using a FASTA
file of a new genome that is from the f9
from spot up Terrafugia para de which is
an insect cell line for the production
of biologics it's going to be a fast
queue file even though it's SRA inside
the SRA is a fast queue file and we are
going to use single end reads now here
we paste that first link so this is
going to be gene expression from this
cell line
once I paste I pasted this link in here
I can also upload my organism so I to
take the second
and paste it in here so now I have my
fast queue file and I have my reference
genome
I don't need any groups because all I
want to do at this moment is visualize
the reeds how they fall onto the
reference genome so I don't need any
groups and now I want to start here you
can see a little bit about an overview
of what RNA seek technology is and I
want to use bowtie to map those reeds on
to the reference genome now what is the
problem with mapping short reads onto
the reference genome the problem is that
computationally speaking this is a very
intense procedure you have to take
millions of reads and you have to put
them onto a reference genome that is
also several million nucleotides long so
this is computationally a challenging
task and bowtie is one of the methods
that could do this now we are using both
type 2 G so we are referencing we're
using a reference genome and not a
transcriptome right you can see mapping
on genome and we are using bowtie - G
the next thing that I want to do is just
visualize my reads so we will use j
browse a visualization solution a
publicly available solution that uses
bam files that will contain the
information about where those reads fall
on the reference genome so this is using
j browse and again remember that the
input into this visualization module is
going to be a BAM file BAM file stands
for binary alignment mapping so BAM file
visualization and now we click on end I
can save for example yeah SS 9
visualization after bowtie 2g
what I say if I have to remember to
click on run pipeline so once I run the
pipeline I will see that it reloads and
I should see that this is started okay
now you don't need to keep this window
open you're submitting a job onto our
cloud infrastructure so once it is
complete you will get a notification by
email or you will also see it right here
under my pipelines so you can see that
right now my pipeline is processing if I
reload I will see how it updates but it
will take some time because I took a
full faster file that's about 2
gigabytes in size and I map it on the
genome of this organism so now you can
see that this is the pipeline that we
built right so we mapped our raw sq file
onto a reference genome and the result
will be a visual output so let's quickly
take a look at what this output looks
like I am giving you here again you
should have the PDF of this presentation
so you can see you can see the the link
right here if I copy this link and all
of you can copy the same link and you go
there or you can always go to pipelines
forward slash and then this is a unique
identifier of your pipeline and you'll
be able to see the result of my pipeline
so this is a pipeline that has completed
you can see that it's 100% done and now
let's take a look over here it has a
button that is called visualization so
what you will see is something that
looks like that if you click on that
button again if you go into the
presentation you can also take this long
link and that will take you to that
output as well what are we seeing here
so you can
see here that we have several tracks
right so several layers of information
on the very top we have the reference
genome it's about four million
nucleotides long and we are looking at
this small section that ranges between
about nine 1.9 million to about two
million two million so right in the
middle we are looking at this small
portion of the genome over here we have
as you can see coverage and snips
so coverage means how many reads fall
onto that segment okay and you can see
over here the scale the scale goes from
0 to about 400 and then underneath you
can actually see the alignment of those
reads and you can see here the red and
the blue those are forward and reverse
directions that we use paired-end reads
from so now we can zoom in okay and we
can see a little bit more detail for
example you're starting to see those
single nucleotide polymorphisms so you
can start seeing how in specific places
there's a change okay and how do we know
what change it is we need to zoom in
even more so we can actually see the
sequence zoom in a little bit more
okay and now you can see what those
changes are so for example here you can
see that this is a G
and it happens in some portion of the
reeds not all of them but in some
okay so as you scroll manually you can
just navigate and you will see the
points over here that indicate a
consistent change so sometimes you will
have change that doesn't occur on all of
the reads sometimes you will see a
change that occurs in all of the reads
so this is just a way to visualize how
those individual reads map onto the
reference genome so this is the
reference gene what is coverage and
again coverage is just how many reads do
you have a lined to a specific segment
you can see that this scale changes as
we go between low coverage and high
coverage so you can see that we will get
to a region that now has a lot of
coverage what does this mean that the
coverage is higher because this is a RN
RNA seek file actually more coverage
means that that portion is expressed
okay is more available so more mRNA was
available that aligns to that segment so
if we zoom out now we can see that over
here is a portion that is expressed so
this is more expression than for example
right here and some regions will have
nothing but of course this is mapping
onto the full genome so we're including
here both the exons and the introns and
so we are just visualizing right now
what is it mean that we align the reads
to the reference genome okay so now if
we continue let's understand how we can
use this information and what other
steps are necessary to be considered
when we talk about RNA seek well one of
the things that we already talked about
is pre-processing pre-processing is
essential for us to get an accurate read
out of the signal that comes from a
next-generation sequencer why because
this is a quick overview of
that process happens we have the
reported genes those genes are on the
DNA and some of those genes are
transcribed into transcripts so for
example out of these three genes gene a
and gene C get transformed into
transcripts and so we have maybe a
different number of transcripts of a and
transcript of C these transcripts become
cDNA and they're shattered so they're
shattered into small portions between
250 and three or 200 to 300 nuclear
nuclear tides law and adapters are
attached to those sequences to those
short sequences so at the end of each
one of those fragments we have beginning
and an end adapter then these are
amplified so the amount of reads is
amplified so that the reading of the
material is more clear and that's when
the reading happens so when we read
right the actual reads that we are
looking at in fast Q files they include
the adapters and they include PCR
amplification how can we see PCR
amplification if we go back here you
will notice that some regions have this
strange kind of continuous replication
of the same Reed sometimes this means
that this is PCR amplification this is
not representative of biological
variation this is just a technical
variation related to the library prep
right so it's related to how the data is
prepared and then sequence because of
that we want to eliminate these kinds of
amplify beams and make sure that we go
back to what was in the original sample
the second thing that we cannot detect
here in the reads because the reads is
what we got as an output is those are
those adapters so adapters actually
interfere with mapping because they're
not contained in the reference genome
so how do we deal with these technical
issues let's go back to the platform
real quick and create another RNA seek
pipeline you can see that these
pre-processing steps are here to help us
eliminate that technical variation so
you can see PCR clean and traumatic
those are two of the methods that we'll
be using to shrimp that factors with
traumatic and remove those areas with
PCR clean so before we move into mapping
we have to sometimes address the issue
of pre-processing now how do you know
whether you have to use it or you don't
have to use it in a lot of the methods
when you read the publication that
describes the methodology you will also
find that they tell you what did they
deposit in the sequence read archive
sometimes it will say that they just
dumped all of their material in there
sometimes they will say that they
actually already cleaned out the
adapters and PCR amplification okay
let's take a look at this example really
quickly where do we find this
information
you
so the publication that we have and this
first alignment data set that we were
looking at comes from this publication
if you just search here for s RR
you will see that they explain where
their data is right so they say here how
many reads in total 48 million raw reads
but they did clean them so you can see
that 48 million reads was transformed
into 47.5 clean reads after removing
reads containing adapters reads
containing poly N and low-quality reads
right so they already did some
pre-processing before depositing the
clean reads into the SRA database and
then give you the accession number so
how do we find this accession number we
can go to NCBI select here sra
right here is the sequence read archive
and input this number right here so as a
result we get that the raw data that
they were describing right and here you
find that information that will be
useful for our analysis for example we
see that this is RNA seek and this is
Illumina data and this is paired and
read right so all of those inputs that
we started with in the beginning
typically they are going to be given
right here unfortunately not always and
sometimes you need to guess or you need
to know by the files that you will
download now how do I get this raw file
I can go over here to the run selector
and I can see all the information that
there is about this
right so you can see that all the same
information is right here and you have
several different links right here
related to the whole bio project or
which organism this is etc so but if I
click right here
so wait until it opens okay so here you
have access to the raw files right you
can see right here so one of the things
that you can do if you know how to use
the SRA toolkit you will be able to get
the raw fast Q file okay so you will
have the metadata or you can download
the raw fast Q file but a lot of times
for example in our case right these are
huge files so you can see that this is
going to be a 2.6 gigabyte file and it's
sometimes you know difficult to download
all of that unpack it and then upload it
back on the on the system so this is
going to take a long time so I'll just
show you a shortcut that you can do
right from here
if you download the run info file it
will actually generate a downloadable
csv file for you and if you open this
file in something like Excel or a text
editor it will actually give you a
direct link so now you can see the HTTP
link right here and this link is
directly to the SRR
okay don't try to use this link on the
platform itself but whenever you're
preparing your project and you plan your
analysis include this link in your
analysis plan
that way we can pre upload it on the
repository and make it available for you
unfortunately just like this it is not
going to work because it is not a direct
link to the SRA file it's just a link to
the folder where the SRA file is so
we'll have to still upload it onto the
repository so this is a little overview
of where this data came from and how to
know whether this is clean data or we
need to do some pre-processing the other
thing that we want to look at sorry go
back is what is the impact of
pre-processing steps so the
pre-processing steps are going to be
most important for highly expressed data
points for example here you can see a
comparison without pre-processing and
with pre-processing what do these charts
tell you these are the the transforms so
long transforms fpkm plus one without
any duplicates okay we are looking at
how do these two samples correlate in
terms of their genes right so this is
sample one this is sample two and you
can see that if we don't do
pre-processing we will have a deviation
right and so what does this mean this
means that for highly expressed genes
the
the highly expressed genes we will see a
biased view of their expression so in
some cases when these files are not
pretty processed it's important to
pre-process them and then we will get an
accurate measurement of expression of
highly expressed genes okay
a little bit more about alignment we
already talked about both i2g and
alignment of reeds to the reference
genome in reality we need to understand
a little bit more of the various types
of reeds so that we know how to select
an appropriate method of alignment based
on what we need to get out so for the
first one when we just want to visualize
the reeds bo types would use the way to
go
but what goes into alignment so whenever
we have a sequence for example this is
our reference genome and this is an
output of the BAM file so this is what's
inside the BAM file that for example for
example bowtie 2g produces it will
contain these sequences these are
sequences of reads and you can see that
they are organized by the same beginning
so that first step in a lot of these
mapping techniques is called indexing
indexing means we organize reads into
groups by their beginning so we try to
align them all of these begin with TCC
GA we put them together these begin with
CC GA we put that next this with ga ga
we put it next right so this is called
indexing and then based on this index we
can align them much faster to the
reference genome the other thing is we
of course talked about the single length
and the parent reads and here you can
see how those genes would be or how
those reads would be aligned to exonic
regions and then how we can use the
paired end alignment so that we better
understand what is expressed and what is
not expressed and so as a result of this
you can see that one of the challenges
will be quantification because what do
we need to quantify we need to quantify
full sequences of genes from here to
here so given different alignment of
reads and different alignment of those
reads to the different regions we will
actually be getting differ
results and so one of the challenges is
going to be quantification so to get an
overview of the major steps included
involved in the RNA seek processing of
data these are some of those steps and
some of those challenges that we first
need to address pre-processing removing
adapters and trimming removing PCR
duplicates and you will see that this is
color coded on the platform in the color
blue the second step is mapping where we
can map unknown sets of transcripts for
example known isoforms we can map on the
genome and we talked about how we do
that with go type 2 or a combined
strategy and so we'll talk a little bit
about some of those methods like top hat
and high set that allow us to combine
that strategy and then the final
challenge is going to be quantification
of expression levels how do we then take
the alignment of reads and say this gene
or this transcript is 100 or 200
expression right and what is that
expression and what values are we
talking about here so to explore how to
do this let us create two pipelines
together and I'll tell you a little bit
about the data that we'll use to do this
so the first pipeline is going to be
very simple we're going to do the
pre-processing steps then we will do
alignment or mapping on transcripts so
these are going to be known transcripts
and then we will use our SEM or
expectation-maximization a statistical
technique to understand where those
reads should be and how do we quantify
them and the second pipeline is going to
be a little bit more expanded so this is
going to be your standard tuxedo
pipeline where you can see how we will
use pre-processing then a combined
technique where we will map on the
genome and identify junctions and exons
construct Aiza forms and then map all of
our reads on newly constructed
transcripts and quantify those
transcripts and what we will get at the
end now before this you receive the file
and I believe that see he'll pasted this
information on this page
so if you haven't downloaded the files
yet please go over here and you can see
that we have a link to the files let's
see what's inside these files inside
these files we have samples SVL that's
the file that we want to use and then
we'll see what the samples are in this
excel sheet so those are the names the
phenotypic information about the data
that we're using so let's first take
samples that svl and and what is inside
this data set so samples that svl looks
like this it's just the link to a bunch
of different files as you can see each
file is mentioned twice so you have srr
2 5 6 9 7 s RR 2 9 2 5 6 97 but at the
end they have underscore 1 and
underscore 2 these are paired end reads
so when you see underscore 1 and
underscore 2 that tells you already that
these are paired end reads and you can
see that there is a number of files all
together in a single reference link so
let's quickly create this pipeline so
first of all we know that these are
paired end reads fast queue files and
this is human data so these are human
cell lines we will use the assembly
grch38 upload files and load groups we
will go to URL bulk upload that is when
we have this svl link we will use URL
bulk upload now under let's let me just
quickly find that file
samples that SPL I choose it define
groups check now you can see that it
correctly identified that these are
paired angry I don't need to create
groups and now I'm going to run two
pipelines the first one you will use
trimmer Matic PCR clean then I will go
to bowtie two t are stem expression
table and here you can read about how
quantification is done in different
measurements we'll talk about this in
our next session and end so this is a
pipeline that uses a simple mapping
unknown transcripts for the cell line
project save and run pipeline and once
you do run pipeline you should see that
it has started go back to my pipelines
and you should see it in green so this
is a little overview we're running a
little bit out of time but this is a
little overview of how do we start
analyzing the data and this is the
pipeline that we just ran together how
do we start preparing and processing
these short reads and how do we map them
onto the genome what does that mean and
how can we quantify the output and so
next time we'll talk about
quantification and please whenever you
are preparing for the next session you
can try and go through transcriptomics
one in transcriptomics one we will talk
about some of these methods and you will
have a step-by-step tutorial
on how to do all of these steps and what
they actually mean so just to show you
where that is you can go to let me go
back if you go over here are the courses
you can see transcriptomics one
transcriptomics one will give you files
and a step-by-step tutorial on how to go
through the steps that we just did today
so if you complete this session by our
next time you will have enough practice
and enough experience working with raw
fast queue files to more in the next
time that we will talk we will touch on
transcriptomics too and transcriptomics
to we'll talk about different
quantification techniques including
differential gene expression and various
adaptations of the regression model to
study variation in RNA seek data in gene
expression data now I would like to
conclude by saying that we did invite
all of you to participate in our
computational neurobiology workshop that
will be at the coming up Louisiana State
University LSU Center for coffee and
technology they will host the annual
bioinformatics conference and this
workshop will be right before the
conference at the same place at the CCT
the Center for computation and
technology we all I think you all should
be getting this link especially if you
are in Louisiana and this is just again
something that you should also consider
the upcoming conference somebody from
our group will be presenting but also
many other distinguished speakers from
around the u.s. so if you're able to
come you can register and so just to
just to show you a couple of those links
this is the link to register for the
workshop so you if you scroll down right
here you can register
right here at the bottom we will also
have remote access so if you're around
during that time we'll be able to send
you the details for remote access and
over here on the last line you can see
lb RN conference where you have to
register as well so if you want to
participate please register there as
well that's all I had for today um if
you have any questions we would be happy
to talk and help you out with any
technical difficulties you might have I
hope that this session kind of explains
some of the pre-processing steps and the
mapping techniques that are used we'll
try and cover more in our next session
and please make sure that you look at
the online materials that we have so
that everybody is on the same page by
the next time and like sahil's showed in
the beginning you do have the ability to
kind of monitor the progress for
yourself and compare it to the progress
of the whole group and kind of see where
everybody is at they think you have